>>> JUST A COUPLE OF COUSINS
TURNING HOUSES INTO DREAM HOMES.
>> WE'RE THE "DREAM HOME
COUSINS."
>> MY COUSIN GAGE AND I HAVE
BEEN HARD AT WORK DESIGNING A
DREAM HOME FOR LILIAN AND HER
QUIET, MILQUETOAST HUSBAND PAT.
WHO IS DEEPLY UNCOMFORTABLE ON
CAMERA.
AND NOW, WE'RE READY TO SHOW
THEM THE PLANS WE DREW UP.
>> FOR THE RECORD, I DID MOST OF
THE DRAWING.
>> OH, BROTHER.
>> DON'T YOU MEAN, "OH, COUSIN"?
[ LAUGHTER ]
>> LILIAN, PAT?
YOU GUYS READY TO SEE OUR FINAL
DESIGN?
>> YES, I'M SO EXCITED.
>> PAT?
>> NOW, WE ALL AGREED ON A
DESIGN.
BUT YOU GUYS THREW US A BIT OF A
CURVEBALL WHEN PAT INFORMED US
THAT HIS MOTHER, BEA, AND HER
27-YEAR-OLD CAT, CHARLES-DAVID,
WOULD ALSO BE MOVING INTO YOUR
HOUSE.
WHICH REQUIRED US TO CHANGE A
FEW THINGS.
>> BUT IT'S STILL GOING TO BE MY
DREAM HOUSE, RIGHT?
WHAT WE TALKED ABOUT?
>> YOU BET, JUST SLIGHTLY
MODIFIED.
LET'S START WITH THE LIVING
ROOM.
>> LILIAN, YOU WANTED THIS SPACE
TO BE, QUOTE, "AN OASIS OF
RELAXATION."
>> OH, I LOVE THAT.
>> BUT BEA WANTED THIS SPACE TO
BE, QUOTE, "WHERE WE PUT MY
CAT'S MEDICAL EQUIPMENT."
>> AND UNFORTUNATELY, THE AMOUNT
OF MACHINERY IT TAKES TO KEEP A
27-YEAR-OLD CAT WITH NO KIDNEYS
ALIVE REALLY CLUTTERED UP THE
SPACE.
>> GOD -- THIS CAT.
>> NOW FOR THE KITCHEN.
WE THOUGHT THIS CAPTURED
LILIAN'S VISION OF AN OPEN
CONCEPT DESIGN.
>> OH, WOW.
>> AND WE WOULD HAVE LOVED TO
BUILD THAT, BUT SINCE BEA'S
GOING TO BE DOING MOST OF THE
COOKING --
>> ALL THE COOKING.
SKINNY MINI CAN'T COOK.
>> WE WENT WITH A MORE CLOSED
CONCEPT FEEL.
>> AND SINCE BEA IS AFRAID OF
GAS, WE SWAPPED THE SIX-BURNER
VIKING RANGE FOR AN OLIVE GREEN
ELECTRIC STOVE AND OSTER TOASTER
OVEN, BOTH FROM BEA'S CURRENT
HOME, AND BOTH MANUFACTURED
IN 1978.
>> BACK WHEN AMERICA STILL BUILT
THINGS.
>> ARE YOU GONNA PICK ANYTHING I
WANT?
>> NOW LILIAN, I SENSE THAT
YOU'RE PROBABLY FEELING THAT
YOUR VISION HAS BEEN COMPROMISED
DOWNSTAIRS.
>> YES.
>> BUT UPSTAIRS?
>> HAS ALSO BEEN COMPROMISED.
WE HAD TO PARTITION THE GRAND
STAIRCASE TO ACCOMMODATE
CHARLES-DAVID'S MOTORIZED
STAIR-CHAIR.
>> BUT GOOD NEWS, LILIAN, WE
WERE ABLE TO PRESERVE YOUR YOGA
STUDIO FROM OUR ORIGINAL DESIGN.
>> YAY, IT'S PERFECT.
>> BUT IT WILL HAVE TO DOUBLE AS
THE DISPLAY ROOM FOR BEA'S
COLLECTION OF WISE QUACKERS.
LARGE, CERAMIC STATUE'S OF DUCKS
IN 1930s GANGSTER OUTFITS.
AND WITH 90 WISE QUACKERS TO
DISPLAY, THE YOGA STUDIO WILL BE
A LITTLE CRAMPED.
SO, WHAT DO WE THINK SO FAR?
>> I THINK THAT SKINNY MINI
OPENED HER LEGS AND STOLE MY
SON.
I KNOW SHE TOOK YOUR SWEETNESS
BEFORE YOUR WEDDING NIGHT.
>> WHAT, YOU TOLD HER?
>> I GAVE MY SWEETNESS.
>> OH, MY GOD.
>> OKAY, LET'S SHOW YOU WHAT WE
CAME UP WITH FOR THE PRIMARY
BEDROOM.
>> OH, THAT'S GORGEOUS.
>> HERE'S WHERE WE LANDED AFTER
TALKING TO BEA.
SINCE THIS WILL BE HER BEDROOM
AS WELL, WE'LL SWAP THE KING BED
FOR THREE SINGLES.
>> AND SINCE BEA HATES LARGE
OPEN SPACES --
>> THE DEVIL'S IN THE RAFTERS.
>> THE 15 FOOT CATHEDRAL
CEILINGS WILL COME DOWN TO ABOUT
6 FEET.
>> YOU'RE 6'1."
>> I'LL CROUCH.
>> BUT DON'T WORRY, BEA, WE MADE
SURE THERE WAS ENOUGH WALL SPACE
FOR ALL THE OLD BLACK AND WHITE
PHOTOGRAPHS OF YOUR
STERN-LOOKING ANCESTORS.
>> THAT WAS WHEN MEN WERE MEN.
>> AND NOW, DRUMROLL PLEASE.
FOR THE PRIMARY BATHROOM,
LILLIAN WANTED WINDOWS TO TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF YOUR BEAUTIFUL
VIEW.
BUT BEA WAS VERY CONCERNED WITH
PEEPERS INVADING HER PRIVACY,
WHICH TOOK THE BATHROOM WINDOW
COUNT, DOWN FROM SIX TO NO
WINDOWS.
>> YOU KNOW THEM PERVERTS AND
TUGGERS WANT TO SEE MY MAKE MY
DIRT.
>> NO ONE WANTS TO SEE YOU "MAKE
YOUR DIRT."
>> HIT HER.
>> MAMA, NO.
>> ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT IT?
>> HIT HER.
>> WHEN WE COME BACK, THE
>> ARE YOU THINKING ABOUT IT?
UPSTAIRS DEMO BEGINS.
>> WHEN WE COME BACK, THE
>> TWO, ONE --
UPSTAIRS DEMO BEGINS.
>> OW.